dan Patrick show brought to you by
Continental Tire Continental Tire
Coach's Corner he's the head coach
Alabama
I was watching training days rolling
with the tide last night the Kobe Bryant
episode it's entertaining you know it's
completely different than the Cleveland
Browns hard knocks and certainly the way
they practice their what is said it at a
professional training camp or practice
is a whole lot different than once said
in college and certainly at Alabama but
the Kobe Bryant part of it that was
really interesting
Alabama opens up with Louisville coming
up on Saturday and he's the head coach
of halav coach there Fritzi he's
standing by alright coach so is there
good morning coach Dan how are you I'm
not bad
I appreciate it every year prior to the
start of the season you come on and not
always breaking news but I I appreciate
you keeping the local media at bay not
telling them who your starting
quarterback was going to be because you
wanted to unveil that on my show so
coach this stage is yours feel free to
tell us the starting quarterback against
Louisville will be well I think the
number one thing is respect for our
players so I had to talk to the players
about that yet I have a plan to do that
so I'm not going to say anything
publicly until both those guys are you
know
informed as to how we're going to try to
play the game so I think it would be
fair to announce it but I totally
understand why you would ask what does
it come down to of who gets the starting
nod well I think in this case it's it's
a difficult circumstance and that you
know one guy has really played a lot of
football here and had some success and
we've had some success as a team with
him playing quarterback and the other
guy is very very talented guy who
whenever he's been called upon has
played extremely well and both guys have
done well you know in practice so
I think both guys are weapons that
should be utilized some kind of way for
our teens benefit so the only question
is which one do you put out there first
do you enjoy sparring with the local
media is it is it is it showing your
sense of humor am I reading too much
into it because it looks like you're
having some fun here Okin um well and
and most people don't understand you
know that forces a head coach I was so
nervous and anxious and all that you
know with the media I was always afraid
I was going to say the wrong thing or
you know I had the answer every question
that they ask and I really didn't
understand how to bridge questions if
you know they were sensitive and and I
probably made some you know not so good
in image for myself you know because of
that and so I've tried to be a little
bit more lighthearted with them and
sometimes I like to just talk fun and
have fun with it it may not seem like
that but you know most of the time
they're all awesome - how long did it
take for you to get used to those
cameras following you around for uh
training days rolling with the time you
know what it wasn't bad they were they
were less intrusive than then I thought
they were very respectful of you know
time always ask for whatever they could
have access to and you know I really
felt like a lot of people were
developing somewhat of a negative image
of our program maybe because of the
success that we were having or whatever
and I really wanted people to see you
know what we tried to do everything
possible to create value for our players
here not just on the field but personal
development academic support developing
a career off the field and as a football
player so all
things are important and I think it
creates value for players and I I think
a lot of the negative recruit inside got
us to the point where you know the image
was changing and I wanted to change that
I had Marcis things but I've got nothing
but positive feedback from them it feels
like there's positive intensity I don't
know if that's by design but practices
seem that the yelling is not negative
right is that by design no absolutely
you know we want to teach when you teach
players something I don't think you need
to be negative I think it needs to be
positive instruction and you know the
only thing the intensity brings is you
know players have to learn how to
maintain focus a mental energy that
allows them to do things at the level
they need to do them to create the
habits they need to carry into the game
so they have a chance to be successful
whether it's technique or a Simon
oriented so I think that's where the
intensity is you know geared toward
maintaining you know that that mental
focus mental toughness that you need to
sustain in the game and but but you also
if you if you're not telling a player
how or why he needs to do something a
different way and you really not
teaching them so um the combination of
those two things are important he's Nick
Saban they got Louisville coming up on
coming up this weekend on Saturday
joining us the Continental Tire Coach's
Corner
did you call Kobe or did Kobe call you
all we wanted Toby to come in so we were
we were excited that he you know would
take his time to come in and visit with
the players and he was fantastic you
know I made my goal and the whole thing
was to get him to play on my noontime
basketball star that I think is a
fabulous job with the players I mean
absolutely couldn't ask for
you know more straightforward candor and
I think they made the players realize
that one of the statements that he made
when one of the players said how the
attitude 460 in your last game and he
said I worked eight hours a day for 365
days a year
if they don't put that part on ESPN and
it was really kind of you know that
great players work hard and they invest
a lot and being the best players that
they could be no different than anybody
else I think sometimes we all take that
for granted but well you have to have
the ultimate respect for him when it
comes to being a true relentless
competitor he's LeBron next while he's
still playing so you know it's a little
harder when those guys are still playing
we had great Louis he was great a couple
years ago and so we'll be trying
whenever he courts blamed but I think
he's got a few more 30 years in them do
you have to be reminded to smile to
enjoy because I think sometimes the
expectations are so high that we forget
to enjoy or we don't look like we're
enjoying does your wife ever say you
know what are you enjoying this or show
that you're enjoying this and I guess I
must even though I don't feel like it I
must look like I'm not but I actually am
enjoying it and you know but it's
challenging and I think the most
challenging thing is to stay focused on
you know keeping the real thing the real
thing
don't worry about all the external
factors and expectations and comments
that people are making and you know what
your rank and all that because you're
not really your ranking rating all that
noise right now beats
I think you know this year's teams play
last year's team so and it's a totally
different team that has to go out and
create an identity for itself so to be
able to stay focused on what you need to
do to develop that and not get involved
in all the rest of the stuff probably is
the most challenging thing you know from
a psychological standpoint to stay
focused on the real thing did you enjoy
this interview or did you act like you
were enjoying this interview I really
did you know like it or not you know
your your your law you've always been
pretty easy you know I like people
who'll ask good questions and they're
not trying to attack you or get you to
say something to create some newsworthy
whatever which I always feel like you
ask you questions but you know you're
not trying to get something out of me
that's going to create some controversy
and once again that starting quarterback
against Louisville is yep that's me a
good luck have fun against Louisville we
appreciate your time as always all right
Thank You coach did you hear the car
door open like he was getting out of the
car and I thought yeah interviews over
here
Fritzie coach you got nine minutes I go
nine not 11 not ten nine I took two
shots at it with the quarterback yeah
boy my favorite is as you told him we're
about to break news about the
quarterback you could hear as you start
the question he goes which is like a
huge laugh for anyone else I thought you
know I tried to help you those local
media and Alabama I tried gave it a
couple of shots there you got you got
coach savings laugh there student see if
you could knit by the way Continental
Tire Coach's Corner Continental Tire
proud to be the exclusive tire of the
Dan Patrick show no matter where you
drive what you drive how you drive
continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit Condon
tire calm continental tire for what you
do for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]